aside from the stalks and the balls most men
[__] like dogs no grace no skill a few dozen
thrusts and done your [__] shouldn't go
near Jesus slick as a baby seal and then
you go inside but slowly don't jam it in like
you're spearing a pig come on you're a lucky man
I'm an amended you bring no enough the people
knew the big woman's still here by freezing
my balls off out there I'll wait to die nice
and warm in here it could be our last night in
this world you know yes well I'm glad you're here
here fighting with us glad you survived Eastwatch
[Music]
Giants milk maybe I will have that
drink pardon me lady Brienne she's
not a sir you're not the night women
can't be nights why not tradition
folk tradition I'm no king but if
I were I denied you ten times over
arise Brienne of Tarth
a knight of the Seven Kingdoms [Music]
Sabri Adam Tom Knights of
the Seven Kingdoms [Applause]